[Music]
sixteen-year-old TJ Kim can't even drive
yet but he's learning to fly and he's
using his flying lessons to deliver
personal protective equipment to rural
hospitals in Virginia the sophomore from
Bethesda Maryland noticed hospitals were
in short supply of gloves masks and
gowns because of the corona virus
pandemic it's all part of a program he's
called SOS supplies over skies started
school was just cancelled and PJ's been
taking flying lessons for a year it was
my dream to become a fighter pilot in
the Navy last year for my 15th birthday
my dad got me what's called a discovery
flight it's where you go up with an
instructor he shows you how the plane
works and what it feels like to fly and
immediately I just fell in love with it
when stay-at-home mortars hit his
hometown
TJ wanted to keep up his training in my
flight training year Anastasia it's
called cross-country flights which means
flights had ever more than 50 miles
together with my dad I talked with him
about ways to come up serving the
community and also doing these
cross-country flights we did some more
research and we found that there are
seven critical access hospitals in
Virginia that we can fly to and provide
medical supplies
every week TJ collects masks gloves and
disinfectant spray from around his
neighborhood we communicate with TJ also
talks with the flight school to get
weather reports he's also in school so
flying is saved for the weekends his
latest delivery brought 3,000 gloves and
a thousand head covers to Woodstock
Virginia hospital TJ says rural
hospitals are hurting for supplies too
and he wants to make sure they're not
forgotten but at the same time has just
been a true blessing I just want to
thank all the doctors and nurses who are
serving on the front lines as long as
they have a need for supplies and as
long as
I'm able to go farther than that's what
I'm gonna do
[Music]
you